You cannot make this up, guys. When I
look at this, hellfire makes perfect
sense to me. It's already made perfect
sense. It just makes extra perfect sense
to me. He's like, when is the
international community going to speak
out? Okay. And somebody will think if
you didn't know who this guys was, he
you will think he's talking about Gaza.
What's going on in Gaza? When is the
international community going to speak
up?
>> Assalamu alaykum. I really want to thank
forever for partnering with Abdullah in
this absolutely amazing very very
important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs, people have lost hands and legs,
some above the knee, some below the
knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example
Ahmed. Mashallah, he's one of the so
many whom we've been able to assist with
your partnership. So may Allah reward
you and grant you goodness and may Allah
almighty continue to use all of us to do
this good work
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well in do not forget
to download the Salah Pro app. All of
our service are for free inshallah. It
gives you salah reminders uh encourages
to pray salah. You can book a salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
find the salah hub, you name it, salah
videos, all there. Let's get straight
into the video, brothers and sisters.
Subhan Allah. Um, Syria has been
attacked uh by Israel as you can see.
Subhan Allah. Sister, I don't know if
you guys have heard this is one of the
journalists on the ground. We're going
to watch the video inshallah and then
we're going to see what's actually been
going down on the ground inshallah with
news of apparent kidnapping that was
that happened that led to this of a dur
man. Dur is a religion that's offshoot
of Shiaism. Sh do of them the kufur as
Sunnis we believe the kufur anyways
they're disbelievers they're not Muslims
and you can see also their loyalty to
Israel some of the a lot of them they
actually encourage their men to go and
join the IDF so the genocidal pro
genocide themselves anyways here's a
video on the ground of one of the
journalists uh telling us what has been
going on and then we're going to come to
an outright threat that's made uh by uh
one of the ministers in Israel the
genocidal maniac I think his name is Ben
if I'm not mistaken may Allahh destroy
him into pieces. I mean, in this life
and the hereafter, calling Jolani a
jihadi. So, let's see what we we can get
from it. Here's his first video.
foreign.
Algeria.
Now the next footage you about to see is
a group group of Dus individuals uh who
are ripping the Syrian flag off and
putting the genocidal flag up. Here is a
video footage of them on the roof.
>> And now the video promises of the attack
of the military headquarters in Syria.
As you can see in the footage there, it
is in Damascus. Uh it's next to the
presidential building. You can see the
attack that took place when Susan is
targeted attack. But as you can see, if
Syria was to do this to Israel where
they using human shields being in the
city in Tel Aviv surrounding their
military infrastructure around civilian,
you know, like I say, every accusation
is a confession. There would have been a
global outcry. I hope you guys enjoy the
video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app. Brothers and
sisters, we are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kibla finder, no ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more,
brothers and sisters. We are not an app
that shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now inshallah.
And enjoy, guys. Let's go back to the
video.
This is the clip of um the people in
Syria calling for jihad. Here's the
footage in
now a group of people when they are
oppressed and they call and what's jihad
jihad is not what you guys think it is
in the sense where you know innocent
people harmed. It is something that is
against oppression against the innocent.
Yes. Is protecting the innocent. Uh
subhan Allah. And this has been done by
the Muslim armies throughout centuries
even to protect minorities like the
Christians or the Jews. The Jews who
have been persecuted for centuries by
the crusaders and the Christians who
hated the Jews. And they were actually
biggest anti antimism come from them
comes from them because the Christians
believe that the Jews have killed their
god which they believe Jesus to be. And
this carried on brothers and sisters
until 1966 where the pope came out and
you know gave the Jews their innocence
by saying you know okay look you know
you know they've been they've been
forgiven you know for that sense. Subhan
Allah. Throughout the history, brother
sisters, the Muslims were at the
forefront protecting Jewish minorities
and some of them, so many of them fle
flee to Ottoman Empire for refuge.
Subhan Allah. And I can remember one of
the rabbis, I can't remember his name.
He said that if Muslims were ruling um
um the world at the time of Hitler,
there would have been six million extra
Jews alive today. So, subhan Allah.
Here's the footage, brothers and
sisters, uh, of Durus individual men who
are going towards the occupied Golden
Heights, which is actually the Syrian,
it belongs to Syria, and they are going
there to fight against the Syrian army
alongside Israel where they're attacking
on air. So, this is the footage that you
can see, broisters, uh, that's what's
happening. And not only that, there's
other footages which shows you that the
Syrian army uh is fighting back and
there's rumors that apparently a Durus
man was kidnapped which led to
escalation between the Sun Sunnis and
the Durus. in that specific area. But we
know behind all of this fitnar mischief
like Allah in the Quran, who are behind
it? The Zionists. The Zionists are
behind it. Yes. Be it the 9/11 attacks.
Yes. Uh we know it's been called a
conspiracy. You know, when they tried to
make Apac a foreign agent that's
operating in USA, uh um I think it was
JF Kennedy who happens to die. These
lucky Israel get so lucky. Subhan Allah.
Everyone, the whole world knows who is
behind all of this fitna and
tribulations. Here's a video of foreign
minister of Israel, Gideon. May Allahh
break him into pieces in this life and
the hereafter. Look what he had to say.
You will be shocked. Just listen to what
he had to say, guys. Yeah.
Oh man, it is so rich coming from this
guy. You can't make up. It is so rich.
The irony. Every accusation is a
confession. Minorities when Al Jolani,
again brother bros and sisters, I'm just
reporting on the news what's happening.
I'm not to probe anyone for this matter.
Al Jalani clearly gave the dur and said
to them that they will be protected. So
you can see these individuals who are
committing a genocide massacre
threatening the ICC head that Mr. Khan
Yes. threatening him. Can you imagine
they are saying that because you are
objective and you are uh issued arrest
warrants they are threatening him. Yes.
This is the democracy. This is the
United States of Israel and America. You
know the western world when it comes to
human values you know human rights they
are upholders of that. You can see it's
nothing but uh you know lies. It's under
that banner which is lies. But let's
carry on.
Oh, he's upset that there's civilians
apparently that these are all, by the
way, lies. These are all lies. But it
isn't, isn't it, Rich? He is concerned
about innocent civilians dying.
You cannot make this up, guys. When I
look at this hellfire makes perfect
sense to me. It's always made perfect
sense. It just makes extra perfect sense
to me. He's like, "When is the
international community going to speak
out?" Look at somebody will think if you
didn't know who this guys was, he you
will think he's talking about Gaza,
what's going on in Gaza? When is the
international community going to speak
up?
You can see how vile these Zionists are.
Like how vile they are. Like the entire
world has seen them for what they really
are. Imagine this is what we've come to
know now because of you know Tik Tok and
all this kind of stuff. Imagine what
they've been doing for the past 60 70
years. Just imagine hellfire is enough
for these individuals. And in this video
brothers and sisters there is a dus
leader who apparently says that he
wanted peace um in the region while the
escalations were happening and then went
back on his word. I wonder who he spoke
to. I wonder if he spoke to a uh you
know uh Benjamin Netanyahu or one of the
ministers and said look you know flip
that. First it was, you know, they were
cooperating with the Syrian the Syrian
army and then he goes back on his word
and saying, "No, the Durus should fight
the Syrian army." As you can see,
mischief makers. When they're friends
with the mischief makers, what do you
what else do you expect? Subhan Allah.
And last but not least, this is this is
Ben. This is Israeli Minister of
National Security. Look what he has to
say about Jalali.
East.
I'll be honest. If I was if me and my
family were been persecuted by some evil
people, the last people that I would go
on earth for backup is Israelis. Wall, I
I would say I would rather be killed, my
family be killed, then go to these
genocidal maniacs for backup. This guy,
as you can see there, he's saying, you
know, people that hurt people and
innocent people, etc., how could you
negotiate with them? He's a jihadi. Once
a jihadi, always a jihadi. I mean, it's
it's so bizarre. Like I mean are you not
doing that? Imagine me as a mass
murderer condemning another murderer or
that murder actually argument sake and
and this is accusation by the way. Yeah.
Okay. So imagine there's someone who
actually is doing the killing. I'm a
mass murderer. I'm known to massacre
people and then I have a go when I say
listen. Are you not ashamed of yourself?
Why are you why are you murdering
someone? Let me speak to this camera.
Why are you killing people? And you're
thinking brother you're known to
massacre people. You're known to kill
people and you are questioning me and we
know what a a a a hypocrisy is. You got
someone smoking cigarette and saying now
why you smoking it's good it's bad for
you. It's it's hypocrisy. So you can see
brothers and sisters what's going on the
ground and I know there's a lot of
speculation of people saying that
Jolandi works with the Israelis etc. you
know without evidence without
understanding politics neither do I
understand myself. Uh but brothers and
sisters um we don't know what's going on
on the ground but I just wanted to bring
this to your attention and show you guys
what's exactly going on. Subhan Allah.
And we ask Allah subhana wa ta'ala to
end the occupation of Israel. It is the
beginning of the end for them. The whole
world is seen. The whole world has woken
up to their mischief from the Epstein
islands, the uh uh um state funded Pedo
Island. Pedophile Island basically where
they used to blackmail figures like God
knows who was on that list, Trump, God
knows whoever uh to twist their arm when
they need it. And that's the reason why
you see Trump, you know, making the seat
ready for Benjamin Netanyahu, taking
care of him, giving him extra care and
attention. Till next time, brothers and
sisters, asalam alaikum.
Do not forget to download the Salah Pro
app and use it promises. Our service are
for absolutely free. We have no ads.
There's kiblinder, salah reminders,
encourage you to pray salah. You can
book a salah instructor, order a guided
prayer mat, watch salah videos, learn
how to pray salah inshallah. And we will
see you guys very shortly.
Medicare.